Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going
to explain an action drama comedy film
called “Big Brother”. Watch out and take care!
Henry has returned to Hong Kong after serving
in the US military for years. Looking to start a
career as a teacher, he goes to his former school,
Tak Chi secondary. The principal notes that
he doesn’t have experience in teaching. But
after being shown a recommendation letter from
a higher official, he is given the job. Before
Henry leaves, the principal informs him that the
class he is assigned to teach is the worst one
of their school. The morning of his first day at
school, Henry walks into the class to see that it
is in absolute chaos. Some students are sleeping,
others are singing, some are playing video games,
while a good number of them are cooking ramen on
a portable stove. Even after the teacher walks in,
they completely ignore him and continue what
they are doing. Henry tries to get their
attention but they pretend to not hear him.
He gives up trying to divert their attention and
goes around the classroom commenting
on the things they are already doing.
The students who are cooking are asked to eat
less ramen because it contains too much sodium.
Henry then approaches a guy named Zufa playing
ukulele and helps him with it. Similarly,
he warns a gamer kid against the radiation he
might receive from staring at the screen all day.
When the students finally start listening to
him, he introduces himself and writes his name
and phone number on the board. The students
laugh because his handwriting is ugly. Then,
someone from the students calls him and asks him
to leave the class but Henry laughs it off. The
kids ignore him yet again and continue with the
activities they were doing before his arrival.
Having enough of it, Henry uses a rubber
band and chalk to trigger the fire sprinkler
in the room. The students quickly spread
out to keep themselves from getting wet.
He finally gets their full attention and
officially welcomes them to his class.
After class, a group of five lowest-ranking
students gathers in the sports supply room
to smoke. The leader of the group Jack has a
crush on an A-grade student from another class.
The others find him staring at her picture and
make fun of him. The group has a rivalry with
the rich and spoiled kids from the school’s
basketball team. They enter the supply room
and mock Jack as usual because he is poor. Later,
the basketball team is practicing while Jack and
the group watch them from nearby. Jack drops a
bottle to the court which causes the team leader
to fall. The group laughs but is given detention
by the school's English teacher Miss Liang.
To avoid detention, they play a prank on her and
run away when she is busy cleaning her desk.
Elsewhere, the school’s principal is distressed
because the education board is planning to deduct
twenty percent of their annual funding. The people
from the board come to take a tour of the school
to inspect where the funds are
being used. At the same time,
Henry enters the classroom where the students
have set up a bucket of water to prank him.
But his reflexes work faster than the falling
bucket and he is able to push it away.
The students who had been waiting to make
fun of him, are left shocked. Henry asks for
Jack’s packet of cigarettes, knowing that
he smokes. Jack simply hands him the pack,
curious as to what he is about to do. Then, Henry
asks Zufa to name the three ingredients that are
in a cigarette. When he answers the question
correctly, he is let to skip class for the day.
Everyone starts to bang on their desks demanding
that they should get to skip class as well.
When they stop, he hands them all a cigarette and
asks them to analyze it. Henry knows that if he
simply mentions the effect it has on their health,
they won’t take it seriously. So instead, he asks
them about the outcomes of smoking cigarettes
and explains how tar forms in their lungs.
For the first time, they pay attention to the
teacher and are actually interested in learning.
After the bell rings, he asks them to return the
cigarettes and the students reluctantly agree.
That day in the cafeteria, the captain of the
basketball team makes one of Jack’s friend
Bruce trip on his leg. This gives rise to
an argument between the groups which soon
turns into a fight. They throw food and tables
at each other, destroying the place. Later,
Henry is informed that five students from
his class have been temporarily suspended
for starting the fight. Henry finds Jack fighting
his opponent in the hallway and stops them.
On being asked to calm down, Jack accuses the
school of being unfair because the rich kids
get no punishment. That day after school, Henry
goes through the files of all five students to
find out more about them. The first guy is named
Zufa, the son of a Pakistani immigrant who is
always discriminated against because of his race.
He is often accused of stealing by the policemen
in his neighborhood. Zufa’s only wish in his life
is to become a musician. The second student is a
girl named Denan. She was a disappointment
to her father ever since her birth because
he always wanted a son. Her entire life, Denan
has been trying to gain her father’s respect.
She even cut her hair to a shorter length and
played with cars to pretend to be a boy. Yet,
her father doesn’t care about her while he
treats her younger brother like a prince.
Then, there are brothers named Bruce and Chris.
Their mother ran away with a man when they were
only kids which turned their father into an
alcoholic. The brothers only had each other
to rely on while growing up. Bruce became
obsessed with video games to escape reality
while Chris worked hard in a grocery
store to make money for the family.
Lastly, Henry can find no information about
Jack’s family background. In the following scene,
we see Jack working at a restaurant as a waiter.
An MMA bettor Jianying arrives at the restaurant
with his business partners. When Jianying isn’t
looking, Jack steals his fancy lighter but
is caught. Jianying’s men beat him up as he checks
Jack’s ID. After finding out that he is a student,
he gives him some money and offers him
a job as their food delivery man.
Somewhere else, Henry visits Zufa’s home and
finds him running away from his father and his
associates after stealing a ticket. He helps
him at first but after finding out why he is
being chased, he takes the father’s side.
Then, he and Zufa come to hang out at the
bridge. To motivate Zufa into doing whatever
he wants, Henry sings with a band performing
in the streets. Seconds later, Zufa joins him
and sings in front of people for the first time
after being bullied at school years ago.
Meanwhile, Bruce and Chris’s father comes home
late like always and orders them to bring him a
beer from the store. When the brothers refuse,
he yells at them to get out of his house. The next
day, Henry meets with their father and convinces
him to go to rehab for his sons’ wellbeing.
In the meantime, Denan’s father brings her a
bag of makeup products and asks her to act like a
girl for once. Denan is furious at him for always
making her feel like she is not good enough. She
applies the makeup on her younger brother and
sneaks out of the house with the car key. She
is about to drive away in her father’s car but
is stopped by Henry at the right moment.
He tells her that driving without a license
is illegal and suggests an alternative. Following
that, they go to a Go-Kart race track. Henry also
invites her father and makes them race. The father
and daughter show no mercy to each other during
the race and eventually end up outside the track.
Suddenly, Denan’s go-kart is hit by a vehicle
but she manages to dodge it. Unaware of this, her
father cries mourning his daughter's death. Denan
realizes that he does in fact love her and hugs
him. The next day at school, Bruce and Chris,
along with a group, are sent to a rehabilitation
center to interview a recovering alcoholic.
They are surprised to see that the person they
have to interview is their father. The students
ask him how he started to drink. The man answers
that he loved his wife dearly but she left him at
the lowest point of his life. Hence, he started
to drink and forgot that he had two kids to take
care of. The man doesn’t reveal that Bruce and
Chris are his sons but apologizes to them. By
the end of it, the brothers are left crying.
Somewhere else, Jack has started to work for
the MMA bettor Jianying. He offers Jack a lot of
money to drug a fighter’s drink in the next game.
Jack is reluctant but is forced into accepting the
offer. On the day of the fight, Jianying sponsors
a fighter but bets money on his loss. Jack puts
drugs on the fighter’s drink but is caught while
doing so. Before he can blame Jianying, he
is beaten up and locked inside a locker.
A while later, Henry arrives there and asks
the fighters if they have seen his student.
The men ask him to return home but Jack, from
inside the locker, yells for help. After finding
out he is being trapped, Henry attacks them and
overpowers them easily. When the fighters step it,
it gets a bit intense but Henry dodges
their attacks efficiently. By the end of it,
he knocks out their best fighter who was
supposed to compete in a few minutes.
In the following scene, they are at the hospital
where Henry gets treated for his wounds.
Jack tries to reveal the truth about Jianying
but is made to shut up. The news makes it to
the television and Henry starts being known
as the man who beat up a professional fighter
to save his student. His popularity in school
grows and the students start to respect him.
They even get up to welcome him to the class, in
contrast to how they were earlier. A flashback
shows us that Henry used to be a prankster when
he was in school. He even threw water balloons
at a student who was playing piano for the parents
in an event. Later, he fought the same student and
broke his hand. He was suspended for the fight
after which he had to fly to the States.
Starting that day, the students pay attention
when Henry teaches in class and study hard for
the upcoming college entrance test. Everyone is
doing great, except Bruce who has grown addicted
to pills. It turns out that while Chris turned
to video games to avoid his family’s problem,
Bruce started doing drugs. Because he is
unfocused, he does very badly in the mock
entrance test. Henry promises to help him but
Bruce grows more depressed with time. Eventually,
he jumps off the balcony of their house. He is
rushed to the hospital and goes into a coma.
The media twists the news and blames it on
the school and Henry for what Bruce did.
The officials from the education board interview
Henry and decide to revoke his teaching license.
When he packs his things and leaves the school,
the students chase him behind, asking him to
stay. They are heartbroken by his absence but
they know that they should ace their upcoming
test to make him proud. From that day, they
study twice as hard to prove to the board that
Henry is a good teacher. On the day of the test,
Jack, along with all his classmates get a text
from Henry asking them to meet in the school an
hour before the exam. When the students gather,
they find out that it was Jianying’s trick
to keep them confined in the school so they
won’t make it to the examination hall in time.
He is doing this to teach Henry a lesson.
A while later, Henry arrives at school and finds
out about Jianying’s plan. He lets the students
free and fights all of Jianying’s people
to stop them from harming the children.
They escape and quickly make their way to the
examination hall while Henry fights Jianying.
While they are fighting one-on-one, Jianying
reveals that he was the guy who Henry had
thrown water balloons at when he was little.
It turns out that since Henry broke his arm,
he wasn’t able to compete in a big music
competition. Ever since the incident,
he hasn’t touched a piano and blames Henry for
ruining his dream. Henry tries to reason with
him but is attacked yet again. They struggle
to get a hold of a knife. At last, Henry gets a
chase to kill him but doesn’t do it. He asks for
forgiveness for what he did when he was little
and walks away. The students reach the examination
hall at the right time and complete the test.
Cut to a few weeks later, they all pass with
flying colors. Jianying starts to play the
piano again but has a lot to practice before he
gets as good as he used to be. Bruce recovers
quickly and promises to attend the next year’s
entrance test. The principal is also delighted
because the board decides to give them a twenty
percent bonus fund because their students did
very well in the entrance test. Henry returns
to teaching and does the fire sprinkle trick
on another batch of students.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.